welcome everybody to pi data
global um
[Music]
the presentation
at this time is from francis alted and i
hope i pronounced your name correctly
francis
yeah
the title is introduction to blosk ii
i'm probably mispronouncing that
an acronym of some type i'm sure the
next generation of the bloss compressor
uh
and francis uh has worked for more than
30 years in i.t in scientific
computation in academia
as well as
industry and is now a freelancer so with
that i'll hand it over to you francis
and just fyi everybody will be taking
questions at the end of the session
okay thank you for the introduction hi
everybody
uh just a quick um correction i am not a
freelance freelancer anymore i am
currently working for the block
developing development team but also i
am ceo
of iron array which is
an assay library for
for competing with compressed data
okay having said that
welcome to the
to the talk i am going to describe the
next generation of lost
which is
fast compressed and persistent data
store
that's plus 2.
okay
now
first a quick in a quick historical
introduction so back in the 1940s
plushannon invented a way to measure the
information content of a message and
call it information entropy
in theory you cannot
compress that as a beyond entropy and
the formula it's very easy to understand
just that piece of eye means this the
frequency of every symbol in a message
to appear right
so
even if shannon stated that you cannot
compress that a bit beyond that
he did not take in account that symbol
ordering and not only the probability of
occurrence is important when finding
ways to express messages
in less space than such information
entropy
in that sense
bloss comes
with so-called filters that are about
reordering that before the encoding
stage
one example of this is the shuffle
filter
uh i am not going to enter in the
details how it works but
it is just about reordering reordering
data
in such a way that it benefits the
compression ratio
when the codex are trying to compress
to compress the data
okay
so
so and this typically this this kind of
reordering typically allows codex to go
beyond the information entropy
so we are all the time
going um
now breaking into
in entropy limits because of disk
of this reordering thing
and by the way bloss 2 comes with
optimized versions of the subfold filter
for not only for intel but also for our
on power process so this kind of free or
the reorderings are extremely fast
so what's what's blocks blast well blosk
is all about sending data from cpu to
memory and back faster than a memory
copy
typically works by splitting
the data to be compressed in blocks for
better case use
and using the typical divide and conquer
approach so every every every of these
blocks goes to the l2 l l1 l2 cache
and it is compressed completely in cash
and then when it is compressed it is
stored in the bloss container so all
here all the data is compressed here
and of course bloss can use different
filters
like shuffle with shuffle and also
different codecs let's say like elsa for
the lead or the standard
um of course
there is a way to to leverage bloss uh
correctly
so typically the the way you do that is
to decompress and operate in private
classes for best performance so for
example in this bloss container
typically you decompress
every block in
internally in l1 or l2 crashes this is
important and one and l2 are typical
private cases in cpus especially intel
cpus
and this it is important in order to
avoid contention involves multi-thread
as we will see later
and the idea is to
leverage all the data that is
uncompressed in this in this crisis and
perform the operations so for example in
this case we are performing a reduction
uh when we are competing the sun and
then we are aggregating all the sums for
all the different blocks to a total sun
so
this is the typical way to
uh to use blosk in order to avoid data
to try to travel
uncompressed to memory
okay
so that a blast is is able to break
memory walls in many different
situations so for example uh here it's a
plot where we are computing a reduction
in blue we have the bars where we are
computing the reduction
in
uncompressed state
okay
and we can see that we have
a bottleneck here
when reaching 12 threads okay
and that means that
with 12 threads uh we are reaching
we are reaching the memory remember the
total memory bandwidth on this machine
or when working with bloss and doing
with the same operation
we can see that when we throw more
threads at the the task
we can see that we can uh
get faster speed than
uh using uncompressed data so this is
the typical kind of accelerations that
you can see with with compressing with
blocks
of course this is this is real data this
is data coming from precipitation
and the total size is
less than three
400 megabytes you can see more
uh details on this blog post here
and then uh here you we can see another
plot in in
in the x-axis we have the time in
seconds for doing these operations where
a b and c are different arrays
we are computing the average the mean of
all the arrays
and every array is three gigabytes in
size so the outcome is also near three
gigabytes in size
so for in green we see the memory used
by numpy and the time used by numpy
then using number that can do faster
operation because number can do
operations in
doing parallelism
and here we can see
iron array
which
also leverages blocks too
that can can perform this operation
using using compression
and we are getting better performance
than number
because we are dealing with uh with
compressed data
and we are not hitting by the memory
bandwidth
and
model neck as
as much as using without data without
compression
okay so
where is block used so blosk is used in
many places in the pipeline ecosystem
already so
a lot of people here will be using hdf5
via s5pi or pi tables of can use
blocks
also tsar
uses blocks by default via the num codex
package
and also iron array is using the next
generation of blosk
so that means that lots
of terabytes are compressed and
decompressed on a daily basis and that
means that it's
it's quite
well proven for the last 10 years
so what's plus two so as i said before
it's the next generation of loss
uh essentially what bloss 2 adds is a
63-bit container called supertank that
expands over the existing 31-bit
containers in blocks one so this is the
super tank and here's the sequence of
chunks
these are blosk one tanks
and we can complement all this data with
uh with metallic
so-called metal layers which are
essentially metadata that you can add
to to the supercharger
there are two kinds of interlayers fixed
length and variable length
with different properties
okay so let's um focus more now in
in the new features of loss too
like filter pipeline selection format
parallel io unpluggable codex computers
there are more features but i think
these are the more important
the most important ones
so let's start with the filter pipeline
so
the compression process how it's
implemented in blocks 2 is that here we
have the original the original data to
be compressed
and then
a prefilter which is a filter that is
defined by by the user
if if
if he wants he or she wants
then
it creates a temporary
buffer which typically fits in l1 and l2
and then it comes the filter pipeline
which is uh composed in this case by
shuffle and this other filter which is
called temperature for n-dimensional
rendering
and and the user has also registered a
new filter here
which is called ur filter one
and we
and this this can be defined by the user
more on this later
so we create the final temporary that
fits that's still in in cash and then
finally the
the final step is the the actual
compression via the codec so we are we
are creating this this buffer here which
is which is smaller than the original
one
and then for the the compression process
the process is the same but
in the reverse order so starting from
the compressed
sources
we recreate the different the different
temporaries and in order to
recreate the original the original data
so that filter pipeline is about uh
concatenating or composing filters and
codecs and as as i said before
blosk it's
it's all about reordering things in
order to help codex to compress better
so this is a very important part of
brush 2.
a few words about the selection format
so we have seen that
that we have super chunks in blocks 2
and there are two ways to to serialize
them one is the contiguous frame
and then there is the sparse frame the
difference among two is that the
contiguous frame everything is stored
you know on a continuous area either in
memory or on disk
whereas the sparse frame
everything is stored
all the metadata is stored in one single
area contiguous area but the chunks are
stored in different spars
in different uh
in different files or
areas either in memory or with our disk
as well
the frame specification is very simple
we are quite proud of that and
it's it's fully documented in less than
700 lines of text so that means that
it is it is very easy
to replicate the format so that this is
important in terms of portability but
especially safety because it's very easy
to to grasp what the format is about and
one of the reasons for the simplicity is
that
the format resting on the shoulders of
message pack which is an efficient
binary civilization form
parallel io
so
[Music]
for those of you that know gloss blosk
has always been multi-threading
multi-threaded
so
there are different threads that they
can
take responsibility for compressing
different different blocks
so the compression press process works
like this then press the filter the
filter pipeline and the codec everything
is going on in parallel inside blast
and then
everything is written in the frame
either on disk or in memory okay and
that means that if the frame is on this
for example that means that
data can be stored
in parallel can be written in parallel
okay
and for the compression is the same
process we start with the frame either
in on disk or memory
and then with the codec and the data
filter the pipeline and then the post
field
and everything works and in parallel as
i said which is
an advantage
if you combine this with veloci mask
uh
on
block mask then you can you can have a
very efficient way to retrieve the data
that you are interested in so for
example here we have 16 blocks in a
chunk and let's suppose that we are
interested just in the blocks inside of
the square on the on the of the red
square
so we defined the bloss mask out okay
where we
say blosk that we are not interested in
this in these blocks
and then bloss is in charge of
the compressing
in parallel of the the blocks that are
interesting for us
and this is especially effective when
retrieving slices in multi-dimensional
data sets so the typical
way to decompress data
or parts of the multi-dimensional data
sets in
in other libraries is that you
decompress the chunks
completely
however
if you are interested just in one single
hyperplane of the of the
on this data set multi-dimensional data
set that means that you have had to
decompress much more data than you are
interested in right
whereas if we have in plus two we have
masks and and we can decompress only the
the data that is more interesting for us
okay
and in keeping also the parallel
properties so of all fiber so blow both
catero which is open source and iron
array supports this
this
suspicion way to to retrieve data
here we see um
the performance for slicing in different
uh
a multi a three dimensional array in
different dimensions
and we can see that in this in this case
iron array can be faster in general
for than either than that for example
that is using blocks as well
except for the dimension where it's it's
already
in this dimension if it is optimized for
for for the chunk
in this case
is more efficient so it's kind of a
trade-off in general you can get general
better general performance without
worrying too much in optimizing or
getting a slices in a specific dimension
you can see more about this in this
in this tutorial
okay and let me finish the this overview
with the plugable codex and filters so
in
in blocks there is a filters registry
in yellow you can see the filters
registry that are official but
the users can also define their own
filters
and the way to define the filters is
just to declare the filters and then
register the filters using blocks to
register filter
once the filter is registered then it
can be used in the in the filter
pipeline of blast
and the similar procedure you go for
codex2 so people can come and start
producing their own filters and
colleagues
on their own and they can register in in
blossom and then start using it
however the most important application
of that is that the
the plugins can be also registered
centrally
and that means that when a user has a
plugin typically they can send a github
pull request to the block development
team
and then the plus development team
does the evolution process and it
fulfills all the all the specs it goes
straight to global registry
and if you don't
the user original user is informed about
this
and
in order to
to restart the process and to fulfill
all the specs the specifications for
register and the
the plugins that are stated in here in
this url
registering the plugins the plugin
centrally
it's very important because that means
that it's there is an easy way to
to deploy uh
user user filters
so central registered plugins are
included and distribute included and
distributed in within the bls2 library
which can be installed using the python
wheels so after this operation just deep
install blocks too
then
all the
officially or the central registered
plugins are available and this is a very
convenient
way to make your filter and codec
accessible for everybody
other features for blocks too
safety and security is very important
for us and we are actively using the oss
flash service for uncovering programming
errors
it's a plus 2.
there is a nice markup
for documentation we are very proud of
how
nice it looks like the documentation
which is very important for us
also there is an efficient support for
special values
which is very important or really useful
for storing sparse data
so for example when there is a lot of
zeros this is an optimized there is an
optimized path for that
and also there is a python wrapper for
blossom that we recently released
version 0.2
so to conclude
um adapting compression blosk is all
about adapting compression to your needs
so in general tackling compression
includes a resilient ways to do it but
basically what you are after is to get
the maximum compression ratio but at the
same time to reduce the compression and
the compression time to a maximum
and bloss 2 comes with a rich set of
codecs and filters that users can easily
try to find the one that better fits to
their needs
then bloss 2 is in charge of
orchestrating this codex and filters for
both parallelization
and also reducing and sharing internal
buffers for optimal memory consumption
and the result is a highly efficient
tool for compressing your weight
let me finish with this strong statement
because we think that data is the most
important part of your system
and the boss development team is
committed to the future of your data in
that um
first we bloss 2 has a very simple
format and hence is very portable and
maintainable
we also have spent quite a lot of energy
keeping it orderly and clean and last
but not least safety and security is
paramount for us
and
in our opinion productivity
it
should be the premiering mechanism for
that therapy and we are all we have
specific pipelines in the continuous
integration for ensuring the safety
of the on the format
of course um
uh i would like to
to thank all the level the block
development team without them we we
could not
present
this or introduce this new version of
blast
and especially thanks to donors without
them we could not
possibly put plus 2 into production
status so bloss 2 came out in
just a few months ago in june
and now it's a version 2.0.4
which is really meant for for production
so yeah that that was my
my presentation
uh thank you for attention and
if you have some question i will
be happy to take it
thank you
thank you very much francis uh really
really interesting i didn't know
anything about this type of uh this
field and uh i'm not sure whether i know
too much more but certainly uh nowhere
to look now
there is a question from richard pilgrim
he is asking what about
the comparison i guess of lost to
dascares
yes we we have some comparisons about
desk arrays
disk array is mainly an abstraction
right on top of the implementation
so
blast containers can also be used by
dusk without any problem i mean blosk 2
is quite similar to
it's just a format and that can be also
on top of
of
from dusk now that can be on top of
blosk
so for example here we are evaluating a
transcendental expression
okay and we can see here iron array
versus dash
in both involve time and memory
consumption in general iron arrays is
very much into into
optimizing not only the time but also
the memory consumption
many times memory consuming too much
memory is also a bad thing because
it makes your
your programs slow down a lot
okay well thank you very very much uh
francis